foreign
called the order of the meeting of the
Health and Human Services oversight
committee for October 28th and uh the
chair appoints the vice chair as clerk
because he did such a good job last time
and so would you call the roll
um
I'm sorry oh I was not prepared to be
clerked today did I tell you I'm not a
very good clerk no yeah thank you
give you official clerk paper thank you
welcome
so I can do this while you're I think we
have form I guess I think we do too all
right well yeah two three
first order of our business is to
approve the minutes of
the meeting of September 16
and it looks like this
you should have moved to prove puppies
and take a minute to review it if you
have not reviewed it already
remember when we approve minutes we
don't change things that have
subsequently happened the question is is
this a true rendering of the meeting
okay
foreign
representative Marsh has been the clerk
and he is absent today so put a big a
anybody need further time representative
Nelson
yes Mr chairman uh in the minutes it
mentions that I had it
rough information what I said at the
last meeting and I did not get it in
time but I have copies here thank you
very much could you pass them out sure
the question
anything else anyone can I have a moment
I I have a procedural question okay when
when we when we do our minutes we just
added representative oh well I think
we're on the verge of adding
representative Nelson supple moment and
then it's how do we how does the public
see the minutes particularly in this
case with representative Nelson adding
something during the meeting
good morning uh for the record John
Williams legislative director for the
Department of Health Human Services
which is an executive branch agency but
here to at least provide some
information on the retention of the
records with this committee which is a
legislative branch obviously committee
the currently the draft minutes remain
draft minutes they're certainly
available and subject to inspection By
Request up into point of time that they
are available within five days of your
convening and as such the public would
have access to making a request for that
within that time period prior to you
taking action to adopting minutes today
so therefore these are not published on
the Committee website but that's not
inconsistent with oh I'll strike that
you should consult with your own
attorneys regarding the consistency and
how that should be published but it is
consistent with the practice that this
committee has been doing for many years
now as to represent Nelson's addendum to
that this is obviously an item of first
impression to the committee uh and uh
but certainly you could take you could
consider taking action on the underlying
minutes and adopting those minutes
presuming with no other changes but then
taking further action on representative
Nelson's minutes if you're not
comfortable with that and you would like
the public to have an extended period to
reviewing that you could certainly hold
off and taking action on the meeting
from September 16th and have a vote on
your next meeting which I believe is
tentatively scheduled for Friday
November 18th
so Karen thank you so much Mr chairman
so my question was simply
if we accept it where do the final
minutes hang where do we put them so
that the public can see them
so currently the
um committee does have a web page under
the general court website and that is
where the minutes have been posted in
the past uh certainly following up with
your committee researcher Miss Christina
Dyer would be the appropriate entity to
consult as custodian for those records
again just for clarity I'm with an
executive branch agency and only
providing this to be trying to be
helpful for you folks this morning thank
you you've been very helpful thank you
thank you uh when we're done you could
run up to the fourth floor if you would
please when we're done the meeting yeah
okay Mr chairman
okay I'm willing to just withdraw those
and not cause a commotion
or we could skim them and accept them
into your choice
it's just a little summary of what was
said by myself
Senator gray
um
because I am representing Rochester and
I'm also on the city council of
Rochester and do lots of other things in
Rochester uh a lot of this is an
internal matter okay that
uh certainly the change from a
non-profit hospital to a profit Hospital
uh makes a lot of changes happen at that
hospital certainly right now the
Attorney General is reviewing whether or
not
um Rochester should do away with having
birthing services at the hospital
and refer their patients down to their
facility in Portsmouth or to other
places again
I I don't think that this needs to be in
our minutes uh there are people that are
out there looking at it I certainly my
family has been affected by the changes
there uh that my wife followed uh her
nurse practitioner to a different
practice uh because she was very
comfortable with that that person
um so you know this is working its way
out that you know changes are to be
expected when you go from a non-profit
hospital to a profit hospital and these
are some of the things that are
happening at that that point the new
chief executive at frisbee I believe is
trying to work all of that out and I
think that he needs a little time to do
that
representative Nelson would you wish
then that this is just for committee
interest only and not to be part of the
minutes that are for public consumption
my only concern is since I'm going to
bring this up at the end since then I
have finally got a hold of or was able
to get a hold of me is the chief
executive officer there I just spoke to
him personally about two weeks ago and
he defends what they're doing at Frisbee
and did not see a problem he recognized
that there's a doctor shortage and my
question was why so many at one time and
it was very polite we had a nice
conversation
is it your wish that this is just for
our eyes only and not to be part of the
minutes
part not part of the minutes okay
chair will accept that now the minutes
as handed out without this uh Amendment
or Edition anyone wish to move the
you already did yeah
I have short-term memory loss but thank
you second representative Solway all in
favor
aye opposed okay the minutes are
accepted
an announcement lest I forget the next
meeting of this group will be November
18 it is usually the fourth Friday of
the month but that's Thanksgiving uh
weekend and we will all be recovering
from what is a tryptophan yeah we're
silly asleep so we're going to do it on
November 18th
that clashes with a finance oversight
meeting so when that happens we usually
meet at one so our next meeting will be
November 18 at 1 pm
chair now recognizes
the head Lori of many lorries
the Department of Health and Human
Services is like a British truck Park
and the proud owner of a Winnebago say a
little bit about where you're going for
the next year please oh well thank you
um so most of you know that I am
stepping down as commissioner on
December 16th and plan to
travel and take a year off in 2023 and
bought myself a Winnebago that I test
did a test trip last weekend with and it
went really well so I will be in Florida
for six weeks in January and then Nova
Scotia for a couple months to see my
family in the summer
so it'll be the first time I've seen my
family in three years since I became
commissioner so I'm very much looking
thank you for your report but you may
add to it anything you wish okay perfect
uh so
the Department's been very busy over the
last several months as most of you have
seen we are seeing an uptick in covid
and not just covet but other respiratory
illnesses and the fear is that we will
see not only an uptick in covet but then
a Resurgence of flu and other
respiratory virus so we are meeting with
the hospitals as recently as yesterday
to plan for any type of uptick in
respiratory viruses in the coming
respiratory season which is typically
hospitalizations are also ticking up as
compared to three months ago but still
manageable at this point
we have a new Telehealth contract that's
going to govern our Council next
Wednesday and that is a Telehealth
program that allows for direct access to
Providers to prescribe paxilovid which
is the antiviral we've heard throughout
the last several months that both some
providers are hesitant to prescribe it
some patients are unable to get an
appointment within the first 72 hours
what's its name again please Pax lovid
thank you
so many patients were unable to get an
appointment within the first 72 hours
which is uh the time frame in which you
have to start the treatment so it's very
similar to some of the other New England
states we were setting up with a
provider to have a dedicated Telehealth
line to get prescriptions for pecslovid
so that contract will be going to
Governor Council on Wednesday and we're
very hopeful that that will help with
reducing negative outcomes and severe
illness in covid
thank you
new mental health program we started in
July called CTI or also critical time
intervention it is an evidence-based
High Fidelity program that follows
mental health patients after discharge
from the hospital for nine months in
other states when this program was
implemented we they saw about a 20
reduction in readmissions
so we started Statewide July 1 we have
182 participants in it which is
extremely good
already seeing some early data showing
early success in the program so very
very optimistic about that really making
a huge difference when it comes to ER
boarding and and mental mental health
patients getting care in their community
Hampstead Hospital
watching our census rise now from about
44 up to in the 60s at this point
Staffing up everything is going really
really well there obviously anytime you
transition from a family-owned business
to a corporate structure or state
government structure there is growing
pains and there is transition time and
we're getting through that
could you just restate that second
number you said up from 44 and now it's
what in the 60s in the 60s
so making it through the transition time
for staff some of the staff came to
State Employment some of the staff went
to the well path contract we are in the
midst of doing the RFP for the next
round of contracts for services at that
hospital
so we will we expect to be releasing
that RFP in the coming the coming weeks
and then we start the renovations for
the closed unit to become a prtf or a
psychiatric residential treatment
facility for youths we have no prtfs in
the state it has been a very clear Gap
in our system
and we're very excited we're expecting
right around maybe a little more than 12
youth that need long-term psychiatric
residential treatment
to be to be in this facility once it
opens which we're hoping to be later
late first quarter release second
quarter of 2023.
that is my update but I'm happy to take
questions
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair
um what what is the prft what's what are
ptrflexia it's nothing to laugh
psychiatric Residential Treatment
Facility
and then uh Mr chair yes I have a late
uh the Army would call it an alibi on
the minutes uh Senator Rosenwald was
good enough to correct the let's let the
commissioner finish up and then we'll
we'll do that okay well it's a related
subject I just want to I just want to
change be able to change in the final
minutes uh my reference to Hampstead
Residential Treatment Facility to
psychiatric treatment resident facility
so that the minutes match the reality
and any objections to that one change to
the minutes saying none okay it's so
changed thank you thank you and I I I
had another question but no go ahead
okay
um
so so uh Madam commissioner um we have
an increase in respiratory diseases and
an uptick in covid
um do you anticipate uh at this point
that there should be any changes made in
uh the absentee ballot procedures uh
such as their what were in 2020 under
the emergency orders or or or have you
thought about whether this should have
affect any election issues election rule
does not fall under the purview of DHHS
thank God yeah but do you have a would
you have a recommendation for the
Secretary of State I haven't even
thought about it and the secretary's
secretary of state has not reached out
to me so as of right now I I don't
believe that there is
um
um in any uh any desire for DHHS to
weigh in on the upcoming election I
would say that although there is an
uptick in covid and other respiratory
illness it's not anywhere near it was in
uh thank you and thank you Mr chair
Senator Rosenwald
thank you Mr chair I have two questions
if I could yes thank you good morning
commissioner good morning
um first on the Medicaid dental contract
do you expect to be on next week's
um governor and Council as
with with a contract yes okay so it will
be on Wednesday's agenda and has have
been released yet do we know who the
event it is usually released uh either
Friday or Monday so it might be released
later this afternoon thank you so that
it that is next week my second question
is over the past year or so the F
through the fiscal committee we have
accepted or appropriated 30 million
dollars in total for two freestanding
Psychiatric Hospital units I understand
one one of those projects has stalled
and I guess is still stalled
but
um we've gotten conflicting information
on how many additional adult beds
will be provided by the other project
and I have not gotten a response to my
emails
from that second hospital system for
nearly
six weeks my emails are going ignored
um how many additional
voluntary and involuntary Adult
Psychiatric beds are we getting for that
30 million dollars we have appropriated
that the the contract for that hospital
is still in negotiations so we expect it
to be for the next several weeks
uh they're
what I can tell you is that the net
increase in beds
not adult but net increase in general is
going to be about 60. I don't have a
final number yet but it's around that
number
one of the things that we wrote into
that contract
is that on agreement from both parties
the use of those beds can change so if
they stand up let's say 12 kids beds or
20 gero psychiatric beds and the market
doesn't there's no need for it in the
community then
upon mutual agreement we can convert
those to adult beds same as if we if we
stand up dozens of additional adult beds
and and because of our community
programs that we've started other drf
openings if there is not the need in the
community for adult beds we can convert
those to to Children's beds so the the
numbers that we end up with when we move
the contract forward by the time the
building is built there they could
change and we want them to be able to
change because the the vendor is signing
a 10-year agreement and the need today
is going to be different than the need
two years from now and certainly
different than the 10 years from now so
when we when we bring the contract
forward we will have a number at that
point on how many adult specific beds
about both voluntary and involuntary
but
that is flexible and I don't I don't
have that number here with me right now
one phone one follow-up yes thank you so
when
um thank you for that
when you refer to the vendor are you
talking about the hospital
uh vendor or are you talking about a
private for profit vendor our agreement
is going to be with solution health so
um the the grant agreed agreement itself
is between the state of New Hampshire
and solution Health there is components
of the contract that allow them to
assign out some of the responsibilities
to a third party and my understanding is
that the plan is for them to partner
with and with another entity to stand
this Hospital up but our grant agreement
anyone else with a question for the
commissioner
representative Solway uh good morning
commissioner good morning to you a
comment for the committee
um and for the public
as you talk about our attempts to limit
the spread of communicable disease I'd
like to point out that we have a
quadruple whammy headed our way
uh covid Spike appears to be upon us and
rates of immunization with booster
internationally is going very very
slowly
but and we have a drug that you've
already mentioned Pax lovid however
practitioners are reluctant to use it
because there appear to be significant
uh rebound effects
secondly we have an unusual event and
that is a spike in RSV respiratory
syncular virus normally this is
considered to be a pediatric disease
however in the last two and a half years
because kids have been sequestered
because of covid they haven't been
exposed and what we are finding is that
RSV RSV infection which we always
consider to be pediatric are now going
up in the age spectrum and we are
finding older kids and young adults who
are coming down with RSV thirdly we do
have an influenza headed our way we have
immunization for it but we don't know
from year to year how effective that
immunization is in my long tenure as an
epidemiologist I have seen it at 90
percent I have seen it at four percent
finally the last piece of good news is
that we will have a normal rhinovirus
season uh cold season so we can
anticipate that the state could very
well be hit with a four part
epidemic of upper respiratory infection
and our only
hope is that with adequate preventions
we can limit that do we have a program
out there for distancing hand washing
masking and immunizations we've got to
alert our public so we have worked very
hard on trying to get the message out
about getting a booster uh this fall
season this is this is the time it's the
same time we get our annual flu
vaccination to protect us during those
High months November through March so we
have mobile Vans out now doing
vaccination clinics and we also have the
Homebound Program to vaccinate anybody
that's in the home
obviously the flu the flu vaccinations
are uh are in the same spots they've
always been in I think part of what what
is happening we've had a really good six
months
with infections rates have been down
hospitalizations have been down and
there's almost a sense of complacency
and as rates start to go up people start
to know other people that got coveted
again or they've been hospitalized I
think you will naturally see some of the
the booster the new booster pick up
the other New England states are seeing
a much higher rate of the the
um illnesses that you that you mentioned
currently right now New Hampshire is not
seeing it as much but the uh the Boston
New York areas are Dr Ballard Dr Chan Dr
Ballard met with all the CMOS from the
hospitals yesterday and they are
preparing
um in that they're ordering uh the PPE
that is required the papers all of those
things
um so everything is available and I feel
like the state has prepared our Hospital
systems are prepared
it but it is up to the general public to
start taking advantage of the programs
that we have set up to do this
commissioner thank you so much and thank
you so much for seeing the state through
a very very difficult time in in your
ask a clerk a question uh uh thank you
Mr chair uh uh Professor that that first
you know three points that you made uh
could you could you drop that into an
email and send it to me so I get it
accurate and Incorporated in the minutes
thank you
any other questions for the commissioner
other than if New England's going to get
hit so badly how many can your Winnebago
accommodate we all want to go south yeah
I've retrofitted it to to fit six dogs
so I'm not sure that I can fit any more
people that's a good answer and thank
you so much it's been a joy to work with
you over the last few years it's been
we've had give and take but it's always
been with the state of New Hampshire in
mind and it's been done right so thank
18 November she could still come back
on the agenda is a report
on the transparency issues with the New
Hampshire Board of Medicine as you know
through various articles
we've come to
wonder if the rate or the level of
transparency in reporting by the Board
of Medicine is worthy of some
improvement
this committee a month ago approved a
subcommittee which I named it's met
twice different individuals in ones twos
and threes have met and
representative soloway has put together
a report it was sent out by me to the
Boston Globe the union later in Channel
9 yesterday so they could be on top of
it it is a working document
and we sent it out to you last night we
have copies of it here for you if you
would go through it
uh does everyone have a copy of
Representative solway's report
unless I'm just misfied
would you make sure we all have a copy
please we have hard copies here at the
end of the table and email copies were
uh set
and okay if the clerk would pass out
what's at the end of the table
it's entitled report to the oversight
committee on the Department of Health
and Human Services it looks like this
and our job as oversight is to look at
this
make suggestions
and on Monday
the
subcommittee will meet again
to polish this up
based on
our inputs
if you get home and read it over again
more thoroughly and have more input
please send that to representative
soloway
over the weekend Monday afternoon we
will look at this once again
it will come back to this meeting of
oversight in our November meeting
November 18th
it I doubt unless you know you people
just really want to I doubt that either
this committee or the subcommittee will
in its own names craft legislation
my guess is that different individuals
from both groups will come together with
an LSR
um so be thinking in terms of the report
but where we're going to go with it
so let's take a few minutes and and look
foreign there should be a period at the
end of Page Three there is no page four
so if you wondered where it went
um by means of appropriate media it's
findings it should be a period and that
I know a few of you have called me and
uh
you've had some questions and I told you
to bring them to this meeting take them
to this meeting and here we are
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair and uh this is uh for
representative salawar I think
um one I I think this is an outstanding
work thank you for everything you've
done on it you've shown really great
leadership I I just uh I I just would
like to see if I can summarize
what this report basically has done for
the public and to make sure I understand
what what we've done I I think what
we've done is we looked into the the
board of medicines reporting and one of
the biggest issues I think we discovered
was that the Board of Medicine in all
cases does not receive the kind of
notices that it might and so the first
recommendation uh or or two really is
about making sure that we're we're
getting
um as a sufficient or an adequate or
appropriate whatever the word is amount
of visibility into what's happening
around the state and have it reported to
the Board of Medicine they they don't
know what they don't know and so we're
trying to fix that to me that's like 50
of this report it's a big thing then
then from there it seems to me like what
we've done is that we've we've
essentially just said you know let's
make sure that the process is for
investigation are okay let's make sure
that we're clear that the Board of
Medicine their reporting requirements
are are appropriate and then because we
anticipate with the additional reporting
that there may be a growth in workload
we're going back to the Board of
Medicine and oplc to say
you you may need to take a look at the
coming workload and and use the the
budget process to request additional
resources should they be required is
that is that a fair representation of of
what we of the basic inherent structure
of of this subcommittee report extremely
well said representative Edwards I
believe even the Corporal standing
outside the tent would have understood
uh from what went on in our
deliberations exactly what we intended
to do and I think that uh We've with uh
what I can only describe as an
outstanding uh subcommittee working on
this this is certainly not uh entirely
my work by any means
we've been able to identify some of the
obstacles in the process of reporting
and we've indicated as you have pointed
out the necessity to provide the Board
of Medicine with adequate resources to
deal with an increased and improved flow
of information to investigate
appropriately and therefore using their
professional discretion to act
accordingly in the public interest and
finally sir to make known to the public
the results of their investigations and
their actions and that last part is
absolutely critical to their
foreign
I have a question when I looked on the
Board of Medicine website I believe I
read that complaints should be directed
to oplc so this question has two parts
number one did I read it correctly and
number two I am assuming then that we
are changing that by this document
should it be accepted
I think that's a wonderful
recommendation Mr chairman uh that did
not come to the attention of the
committee I'm glad that you've brought
it up and certainly we can make that
recommendation
oplc is the office of Professional
Licensing and certification
and currently a committee is at work
coming out of Senate Bill 330 which
looks at the interface between oplc and
the 50 some odd boards that it works
with
there has been some question as to
what oplc's actual role is it is it
secretarial service is there oversight
do they take some of the work from some
of the boards that will be determined
but we will need to make sure as this
document gets polished up
first of all I think that it is really
our intent that the Board of Medicine
will do the investigating work and not
oplc and secondly that perhaps we could
state that as a specifically as a change
that is being made
any other yes Senator Rosenwald
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative solo hay for your work on
this
um
I I've read this report
two or three times
um and I'm trying to
look at it
with knowing that the special regard is
for the issue of transparency that was
the focus and so given that
the mission of the
Board of Medicine is to really to
protect public health and safety and
we're
wondering how to increase transparency
the only thing I questioned in here is
on page three in the investigation
section
um you said wherever possible and
practical
investigating committee shall include
citizens attorneys and clergy and I'm
wondering
um why why clergy and not Medical
ethicists
since part of the mission of the board
is to make sure Physicians are
practicing safely
and ethically why
the subcommittee
made that
determination not to go with it with an
ethicist if there were investigations
involving ethical practice
well thank you for the question Senator
uh thank you for your wisdom on that
um
the term clergy was used
I think out of respect for a substantial
number of clergy present in the state as
opposed to the number of medical
ethicists that are available within the
state and the hope that our clergy would
likewise be Adept at ethics however I
think that the term medical ethicus it
would be a boon a
a very positive in addition to the
operation of the Board of Medicine if we
can find them
let me respond to that in that this past
Monday we constituted the I don't have
the title correct even though I'm the
chairman of it
um
a committee of ethicists to advise DHHS
this came out of Bill 1045 House Bill
1045 and we brought together a variety
of ethicists from numbers of disciplines
including a professor of Ethics the
ethicist go-to person from the
Psychological Association we have a
go-to person when lawyers want to talk
about ethics they go to this person we
skim the cream so I can find some
ethicists if I'm asked to
the second reason I didn't put the word
clergy in here I was quite surprised
when I saw this and I wondered why
um
most clergy at least perished clergy
are in the hospital a lot visiting sick
parishioners so clergy probably see a
lot of medical care
good bad and indifferent and I remember
my student as a hospital chaplain
full-time when I actually went to the
um
executive director of the particular
hospital and said look I'm not filing a
formal complaint I am strongly
suggesting you look at a particular
thing that I've now observed with one
person on three occasions and I don't
know what they did with it but I saw
that because I was there so uh certainly
I would say a member or two of the
clergy in fact we have one who has a
master's degree in ethics and she is my
vice chair uh um Democrat legislator
from Exeter so I would want to keep
clergy in the sentence as long as you
don't pick me
but certainly add ethicists
to the list absolutely
uh reply Mr chairman reply uh Senator
picking up on uh the remarks earlier by
representative Edwards uh what you see
in that paragraph is our attempt to make
the Board of Medicine more inclusive for
the public interest
and by specifying
non-physician members in investigation
that was our hope I think the addition
of the medical ethicists makes very good
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman I would I'm glad that Senator
Rosenwald brought up that issue because
I I looked at that same sentence with a
certain amount of um uh questioning and
and in part I think it it is probably
appropriate but perhaps not in that
paragraph because at the beginning of
that paragraph you're still referring to
the internal review Committees of
organizations such as Hospital group
practices Etc and as such those internal
reviews are oftentimes protected under
quality assurance such as m m quality
assurance meetings and stuff like that
so it may not be the most appropriate
place to have not non-clinical folks
involved but I believe that the Board of
Medicine in their review of any
complaints or issues do have
non-clinical people
from various professions sitting in
their board reviews so again I think we
have to iron that out but
my sense is that when you're referring
to internal view committees we're
talking specifically about committees
that are part of Health Care
organizations and much of that
information is in a sense not
discoverable so I'm not sure its
position there is necessarily where we
want it though it does come into play in
the Board of Medicine inquiry so it's
probably one of those things we need to
discuss when we meet again on Monday
uh thank you representative put an arrow
moved it down and we can discuss that on
Monday thank you for your continuing
input this year I would appreciate it if
you would find out exactly what
non-medical people are on that board to
see which board are you referring to now
the internal we were referring to
internal Committees of organizations
which oftentimes are where much of this
information is gathered in
it to my mind
the there are two major issues that we
were charged with one is to get that
information from those organizations
whether it's a solo practice a group
practice a hospital a nursing home
wherever how do we get that information
to the Board of Medicine number two is
the issue of transparency and what is
released but I will try to find out
specifically but in many of the
organizations I've been part of those
internal reviews do not necessarily
include a large swath of non-clinical
folks for for various reasons but and
once again you did a wonderful job
representative and
to those in the audience who wish to
weigh in over the weekend
um talk to him
I I I'd like to make a motion when
you're ready uh when I'm ready okay
also we are inviting to the party on
Monday afternoon
uh those from the hospital Association
the Board of Medicine oplc
um doctors Association the various
stakeholders
we would like you there
um
if you haven't received this report I
would like to get it to you let me know
we'll make sure you get it because
Monday will probably be the last real
big
work on this
so you're all invited and I'll make sure
emails go out representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair because I think we
have consensus that the investigations
paragraph may need to be tweaked a
little bit what what I'd like to
recommend or make a motion is that the
HHS oversight except this as a draft
um so that we can read it into the
included in our minutes and that when we
finish the work on Monday then then well
the next one will be the final so to
clean up my motion uh I move that we
accept uh representative saloway's
report uh as a draft uh
for now I I will second that with the
light
any discussion
all in favor
next item on the agenda is the other sub
committee that was appointed the task
force on Precision medicine and bio
marking
marker testing
and representative soloway chairs that
committee
and would you make your report please uh
thank you Mr chairman the task force on
Precision medicine was impaneled to deal
with an initiative uh brought
to the house uh the community on Health
and Human Services by representative
Catherine Rogers of blessed memory no
longer among us it was her hope that in
her own
struggles at the end of her life
to make available
on a larger scale to citizens of New
Hampshire the benefits of what is known
as Precision medicine this was an
extremely
well-intended and generous effort on her
part and as a result this was remanded
to the oversight committee where
chairman Pearson uh constituted this
task force on Precision medicine and
biomarker testing
to his credit he appointed several
people to this subcommittee this task
force
including
Representatives Woods Representatives
Merchant
representative Canon representative gay
and myself and we have worked hard on
that but I must say that as an interim
report the focus of that effort on
Precision medicine has changed markedly
as a result of the insights of
Representative Woods in particular and
representative Merchant I'll try to be
more specific
both representative woods and
representative Merchant bring to the
task force of professional reputations
in regard to areas of the science of
medicine and they have pointed out that
while Precision medicine
is a very attractive concept it is not
yet a proven uh tactic
in dealing with disease it has not been
subject to clinical trials it has not
been subject to
uh uh case controlled studies and as a
result we really don't know how
effective it is we had excellent
testimony that came to us from
um uh Medicaid from uh Ms Clifford who
runs uh the pharmacy section of our
State Medicaid office who pointed out
that Precision medicine itself can be
extraordinarily expensive and the
funding burden to State Medicaid for a
very small number of cases could be
quite quite High quite high in in the
multiple Millions
um representative woods and
representative Merchant pointed out that
this discussion applies not only to
Precision medicine but it applies to
emerging medical Technologies generally
and it was their recommendation and this
is in draft this is uh still under
discussion for a reason that I'll
explain in just a moment they suggested
that it would be more efficacious
to craft a recommendation to the
oversight committee for the creation of
a task force on emerging medical
Technologies which would include within
its purview Precision medicine to be
sure but all emerging medical
Technologies as well uh so that draft is
in process the reason it has not come to
you yet
is that uh at our meetings and there's
just a fruit note
um our first meeting was held in the
Legislative Office Building on a Monday
morning and we learned that the heat had
not yet been turned on in the
legislative office building so as we sat
in committee the temperature in the room
was 57 degrees
despite that chilling effect
um we met for an hour and a half and
were able to listen to testimony to
extensive testimony from representative
woods and representative Merchant that
we focus the committee uh we then met at
a later meeting uh a little over a week
ago and unfortunately we did not have a
quorum which could approve a draft so
we're hoping to have a quorum this
Monday morning that we will have a draft
in place and we'll be able to report
that back to the oversight committee on
the 18th Mr chairman and I thank you
would you shoot me uh that draft as soon
as you've come up with it so I can run
it by the various appropriate
authorities to make sure it's uh the way
it should be thank you
thank you representative Solway for all
the work you've done in chairing this
subcommittee and for your report
next up is the reports of Adverse Events
the annual report there must be a lot of
Adverse Events in the course of a year
and you're going to give us a sampling
of them
and so um would you introduce yourselves
you passed get first test in this
committee is turning the mic on thank
you you're welcome thank you Mr chairman
committee members for the record my name
is Dorian Shockley I am the manager of
the Bureau of Licensing and
certification at the Department of
Health and Human Services overseeing all
units from that are licensed in the
state of New Hampshire from birth to end
of life with me today is Lizette who
will be
providing the annual report on Adverse
Events after she introduces herself
thank you
good morning my name is it I'm from
Health Facilities I'm one of the
supervisors under Doreen
um so I have provided a report you
should
copies
um 2021 report there we go thank you
let me ask before we get uh going to get
going
I heard licensing and certification for
DHHS how does this connect with oplc
um we're not connected to oplc we're
Health Facilities licensing and child
care programs not individuals with
licenses so it's facility facilities so
I oversee Health Facilities
Administration which includes adult
licensing
um I are also our federal CMS team for
all certified hospitals nursing homes
ambulatory search centers and then I
also oversee child care licensing and
um Community residents so this is this
is part of a larger Bureau Child Care
Facilities or workers or both that's not
workers none of the units I oversee are
responsible for individual professional
licensures thank you you're welcome
thank you
foreign
adverse event reports
um first and foremost it is important to
remember that consumers should not
compare the quality of care and safety
of the facility spend a number or types
of events reported consumers needs to
look at all facts factors such as the
size of the facility the scope and
complexity of procedures as well as the
number of procedures and services
performed at the facilities the
population is forever changing with
higher Acuity in care com and
complexities in care some patients are
requiring more time in the hospitals the
covet pandemic also presented new
um
so I'm on page three there were if there
is a graph on the New Hampshire
seriously reported reportable events
from 2010 to 2021
um just kind of shows you
our Trends
um for 2021 we have a total of 90
Adverse Events reported and which is a
decrease from 2020 which is shown in
that graph
um the areas that continues to be
um
frequently reported Adverse Events are
in page five
um
which are
surgical events
um stage three stage four and then
stageable pressure injuries and Falls so
there are about 34 Adverse Events
related to pressure injuries switches
actually in Page Six
um 27 related to Falls which is on page
seven and then a total of 17 adverse
event reports related to surgical vets
which is on page eight considering that
these event types represents about 87
percent of the total adverse event
reported it is important that we
continue to focus our efforts on these
and address what the facilities are
doing in these areas to improve we did
list down some strategies for pressures
false and surgical events just utilized
by these facilities such as for pressure
injuries would be developing proactive
approach in skin management from
admission ongoing assessments and
monitoring of high risk skin breakdown
areas all floating treatments and
devices involvement of interdisciplinary
teams such as the nursing team providers
wound care team dietitians and
standardized communication between
interdisciplinary teams
um for fall such as early identification
of high Forest patients and ongoing
monitoring assessments to ensure
appropriate fault prevention
interventions are placed educating staff
and patients of thought prevention
measures or intervention and its
importance and standardized
documentation and communication between
interdisciplinary plenary teams for the
surgical events
such as like team building strategies to
promote just culture and expectation of
speaking up and problem identification
by all surgical team members reinforcing
implementation of No Interruption zones
for a critical phase such as timeout
process
um
so those are some of the strategies that
the
facilities are using the bureau samples
over 10 of this Adverse Events the beer
asks for and received specific
performance data as a follow-up to their
corrective action plans and all facility
samples provided performance information
it was concluded that the hospitals
followed through with their corrective
action plans
that's pretty much
if you have any questions I have a
question upon investigation of something
that a facility reported as an adverse
event
I could see three possible responses
number one you make recommendations hey
it would be a good idea if you did this
secondly you give orders I.E here's a
mandated action plan but also free if
you've had a mandated action plan
and it didn't get put into practice
at what level are you punitive do you
refer to law enforcement or the Attorney
General's office or if they just plain
don't do what you've now told them to do
what do you do next
yeah yeah so um thank you for the
question Mr chairman um the answer is a
little bit more complicated because this
is our federal team our um CMS team so
we have state law and then we have
Federal Regulations under state law
um we are able to if um and all of the
CMS certified facilities are deemed
licensed which means they have to comply
with the law and the rule so we can take
administrative action if we do give a
directed plan of Correction to a
facility and they're not following
through we have um we would work with
our regional office from the federal
team to notify them of their
non-compliance and in sometimes they
will assess fines depending on the
severity of the non-compliance and the
implications to the health and safety of
the residents and or patients
this would be done by the regional
office and not by you yourself no
um it would actually
um in many cases come from both the
state and from the federal CMS team okay
we work together with them we can't take
so the difference between these
facilities and other facilities that are
not CMS is we those those types of
administrative actions come directly
from me
um in the case of the CMS team we have
to work with our regional office out of
Boston and more often than not they're
the ones that are going to assess the
fines and send the letters from the
federal government copying us has it
risen to the level where they still are
obdurate and their license is now lifted
I'm unaware of any situation in these
types of facilities where that's
happened and also we haven't had to do
that in any CMS certified facility that
I'm aware of but I can certainly go back
and see if historic I've been with the
department for five years and we haven't
had to do that but I can take a look
back if you want to know historical if
we've ever had to do that I infer that
it could be done however oh yes thank
you you're welcome any other questions
representative soloway Mr chairman of
field permit I actually have three
questions that I would like to ask and
they are soft lobs to our presenters
the chair recognizes
my friend Dr soloway for soft lobs
looking at the reportable events by
Hospital
would you like I'll give you the three
questions you can prepare would you like
to uh identify the role of case mix in
the number of reportable events that
occur okay case makes varies okay
secondly uh given the spikes that we've
had over the last three years would you
just give us a word about the impact of
the overtaxed capacity on hospitals of
covid
and thirdly and this question comes from
my wife who's not in
um would you like to comment on what
effect a shortage of our ends in the
um for your last question about the
staff shortages
um
some of the reports does indicate
because they do like a comprehensive
um root cause analysis and looking at
different types of factors contributing
factors that would lead to that event
um
staff competencies
um and kind of knowledge of facility
protocols they are
there's a lot of traveling nursing staff
that's you know
um in the kind of healthcare
World hospitals you know everywhere so
that is one of the things that they've
that I've seen in the reports that I
receive
um
but not all some of the reports
there's really no I'm I was looking at
the reports and the amount of reports
that they've sent us there's really no
change they've been really consistent on
reporting Adverse Events to our
department
um
the only thing that they've reached out
to me is the time frame of and how
they're doing the root cause analysis is
because of covet they're unable to like
meet up meet up as a group so they had
to do virtuals they had to kind of work
things out virtually which made it a
little bit difficult for them to really
kind of do a more comprehensive like in
a timely manner but they're able to you
know at least
um
do some corrective action plans
immediately and then kind of like on the
overs overall oversight is kind of still
ongoing
um could you elaborate on the case mix
please with with pleasure I thought
you'd never ask
as we look over the individual Hospital
data we see variability in a reportable
events
um in part this may be affected by the
mix of cases that get referred to
hospitals so in in fact if you wanted to
understand how uh efficiently hospitals
were dealing with uh potential
reportable events you would want to take
a look at the diagnoses and complexities
of affecting patients that get referred
to them so some of our hospitals have
higher numbers of reportable events uh
because of this dual problem of
difficulty in Staffing I think your
comment about traveling nurses is very
well taken and you place that in the mix
with
um complex referrals and you have a
difficult situation facing a hospital
and that gets reflected in the number of
reportable events so I'm trying to take
some of the onus off of the hospitals
that have higher numbers that's a really
great point and I really appreciate you
making that point is that something we
look at now and if not we I don't know
that we do I mean looking at the reports
by the hospitals you can definitely see
where the highest
um frequently reports are and if you
look into the hospitals it's really like
Center
like New Hampshire which like from like
some of them are Manchester conquered
because some of the hospitals are far
away and they get referred to like more
of a bigger hospitals than you see and
they take more
um complex patients
which are more sicker and so you kind of
see more higher numbers there because
they do have and you have to consider
bats as well the services that they
provide so you'll definitely see higher
numbers on like hospitals that provide
more services and kind of higher complex
services
as a follow-up is there something you
would like us to add to the report going
forward
um in regards to that
topic or is it something you just want
us to be considering as we're looking at
it do you want to see I'd just like you
to be considering it but I also uh
wanted the committee to understand the
meaning of some of the data and I wanted
to thank you for significant efforts in
sorting this out thank you very much you
know these are the times when I just
wish we had somebody from the hospital
Association here today why I recognize
Paula menahan from the hospital
do you want us to move or
well they're not going far
thank you chairman Pearson um for the
record column in the hand um Hospital
Association but with me today is Rory
Dawes Diamond
d-a-w-e-s apostrophe
d-y-m-e-n-t she is a nurse and the
director of the center for quality and
safety at Southern New Hampshire health
and she is a member of the quality
commission and I think um uh Rory could
add to some of the presentation and
comments from the Department if you have
a business card could you give it to me
I I would love to my assistant ordered
one after last month when I presented to
you so uh I they are unfortunately we
will accept your name written on the
so certainly I appreciate the
opportunity to fill in a little bit more
um of the work that we have been doing
um as Lizette alluded to a lot of
challenges this year and the past couple
years related to covid
um in the beginning of covid we were
seeing a lot of
um changes in our fall raids and
pressure injury rates and that was
related to how we were caring for our
patients at that time uh since that time
we've seen the effects of the Staffing
significantly as we mentioned with The
Travelers Not Just in nursing but we're
having a lot of locums in terms of
providers so
um you know and anesthetists nurse
anesthetists anesthesiologists we've had
a lot of turnover with our providers as
well
um just a lot of people in different
areas are looking for new opportunities
and as these new providers and new
nurses and new other support staff are
coming in our orientation process change
during covid so a little bit less
Hands-On and a little bit more remote
out
introducing our new employees to our
culture and there's not necessarily an
investment in a Hospital's culture when
a provider or nurse is only there for a
limited amount of time and their
contract ends and there are no they know
that they're moving on to something else
so we've been working very hard in the
commission the quality Commission on how
we can improve those Communications
among our team members introduce those
new team members into our cultures and
how we do things it's been a challenge
for sure
unfortunately Chris Herring is not able
to be here because she had a meeting
with our chief nursing officers in the
state but we are looking at some
resources by the ahr Q on implementing
team steps which is a process of
communication in healthcare settings how
can we enhance that in our current
settings where we don't necessarily have
the situation we had four or five years
ago where we had a solid group of people
that
stayed around so lots of work on that
representative Edwards
thank you um I appreciate all of that I
I was my questions were actually for the
first panel okay I have a question for
anybody
um on page three the uh the chart
serious reportable events 2017
58. the next year is 112 that's
pre-coveted so there was a huge jump and
we're seeing the numbers going down so
notwithstanding the fact that floating
staff members mainly
foreign
not quite be on board with what you're
doing to the degree your regulars are
I would have expected the big jump in
the last few years but I'm seeing it go
down and from your perspective and I'll
ask the previous two presenters why the
big jump from 2017 to 18. I believe that
I will look to uh my DHHS colleagues but
I think there was a change in um a
couple of the metrics
turn it off sorry you caught yourself
though that's good
um so over the years reporting coach I'm
working with the New Hampshire Hospital
Association has improved that culture of
reporting and just awareness and kind of
continuing education with the staff of
reportables even with changes
um
you can see that in the report that the
jump is
just because of the reporting culture
kind of working with the New Hampshire
and it's yeah so things haven't gotten
worse the reporting has just gotten more
precise correct good thank you now
they're back representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair I um I got a couple
questions in the summary section uh one
page no it's page nine
uh for I think this may be for Miss
Shockley
um the the last paragraph talks about
your annual sample of 10 percent
and so that that kind of jumps out at me
as potentially interesting information
on on how your actual audits what what
you find and I'm just curious do you do
you report that anywhere it's not in
this report it's actually a question for
can do you want to look at the paragraph
it's really the selecting the 10 is
random
um so there's really we just just we do
quarterly I look at the numbers and then
just pick randomly
um the hospitals or Adverse Events and
then reach out to the facilities and ask
them for evidence of their craftive
action plans so the corrective action
plans that they provided within that 60
calendar days to be submitted like after
like
um
because I look at the time frames that
they would put in for their corrective
action plans like how long they
um expect that to be
um
corrected so in the interest in time my
question isn't about your methodology my
question is on the extent it is a great
answer to a different question but my
question really is
um do you have a separate report that
focuses on this 10 percent that you go
do an audit on because when you go do an
audit you find out are they doing it
right are they not doing it right I mean
that's why we do audits right I think
that's what Lizette is
um saying trying to say um but also
giving more information so we are
looking at that and then doing
follow-ups to make sure that that 10
percent did do as they had said they
would do is that no I'm still asking
about how you report it to us that 10
the findings of the 10 that's not in
this report
but the audit effort is distinct and I'm
just curious if you find anything
are you did you say you understood
because I don't understand I'm really
sorry I'm not understanding are you
asking us to put more information in
this report about the 10 like what we're
finding when we're doing the audit would
you like to see more information about
those results I'm really sorry I
personally would yeah because an audit
is uh and and kind of a verification
validation tool and I'd like to know are
we validating through these audits that
our reporters are doing the things that
they should be doing or these validation
efforts indicating that we're not really
complying well I I assume because it's
not in here that they're probably
complying well and it may just be a
sentence or two correct and I think that
kind of goes hand in hand with what Mr
chairman asked earlier in terms of what
action do we take if they don't follow
the corrective action plan we would do a
directed plan of Correction and if that
isn't followed then we would take
administrative action with our regional
office
um but I we haven't had to do that
because people are being compliant
um so I if I think that's what you're
asking so but we will um certainly going
forward if in fact there is
non-compliance after providing a
corrective action plan or a directed
plan of Correction then we would
certainly include that to let you know
going forward in the time that I've been
here we haven't had to do that and I
don't know prior to the five years of my
being here
follow up yeah I I appreciate that and
that my assumption was that you were
finding things to be fined you're in the
audits but I didn't want to make an
assumption when we had a report here so
so thank you for for sharing that the
next item I'd like to ask you about is
um the second paragraph of the summary
where it says on patreon facilities are
increasing their ability to identify
events last year when uh your
counterparts or maybe it was you I have
a bad memory but uh when when you all
came in I thought we had a very nice
conversation about the culture of
reporting and sort of the good faith uh
efforts that are necessary by our
hospitals to self-report bad news
self-reporting bad news is a hard thing
to do
and I think in your testimony last year
we we were kind of proud that we had
instilled that sort of reporting culture
and so so when I look at this paragraph
it says we are increasing their ability
to identify events that would conflict
with last year's testimony that we were
just great the reporting culture was in
place we were just great and so if we're
great are we increasingly great I I just
I'm nitpicking the selection of words
here because if if we don't get the
culture right on reporting then this
entire report becomes questionable and
and and and so the health of the
reporting culture is so important to
this whole process it's almost like it
should be its own paragraph how how are
we doing from managing and maintaining a
healthy reporting climate
that that's that's more common than
anything else but if you'd like to
respond please and I appreciate that and
and you're right um it is
suggesting that we weren't doing as well
as we stated last year which we were
doing that well I think what we really
work hard at and that's in collaboration
with you know the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
um as well I mean I think we hear
regularly that in New Hampshire the
relationships between the state
regulatory body and the facilities that
are serving our residents is much
stronger than it is in other states and
we're really excited about that so I
think and and it's been a really rough
ride of recent times right and which
makes even reporting as you had
mentioned earlier even more difficult
when you're running around you know
short staffed Etc et cetera so I think I
think our point there was just that
despite everything that's happening and
in our environment we are still really
pleased with the collaborative effort
between our office and the community but
we will do better going forward at
articulating exactly what we mean
follow up so the reason I I think you
might want to go into a little bit more
depth is because the centrality of how
important this management of the culture
is and it and it's sort of good news so
I I would like to see everyone involved
in this take a little credit for doing
the hard thing which is self-reporting
and if we you know for example if we
ended up having some hospitals open or
closed or change hands you know that can
take a cultural hit on our overall State
situation and if if that were to cause a
cultural reporting problem it would be
good to make sure that we knew about it
thank you
any other questions
Senator Rosenwald thank you Mr chairman
um just simple question the physical
assault the one instance was at an
assault of a patient by a staff member
patient to staff
Senator gray did a whole lot of work
leading
a huge effort on Health Care workplace
violence and what we kept hearing was
that assaults of Staff by patients
keep going up so I'm sort of surprised
to see only one instance
and I wonder if you could elaborate on
why that is because if it's only one it
seems like
something really good
happened in that environment over the
past year
so for the the uh the Adverse Events
report then the guidance that we get is
from the national quantity forum and for
physical assaults
um the guidance are the definition is if
there's death or serious injuries
yeah
I think I'm I'm really processing this
because I I understand and I've been
part of the many groups across working
on that legislation we have to also
remember that these are specific
um facility types but my thought would
be I mean first of all we're going to
need to go back and look at some of the
information but if the definition is
such that
um in other cases where they're um where
a staff member is injured it may not
have resulted in a serious injury or
death and in this case it did or the
interpretation of the facility is that
it did so it might be that we need to
take a look at that and I don't know if
Chris is here
right there sure come on up here thank
you very much if he sits in there and
hits the button I think that all three
of them proving I am not mentioned here
thank you thank you very much my name is
Chris and speak into it all right thank
you my name is Chris Herring I'm vice
president of quality improvement at the
foundation for Healthy Communities I'm
administrator for the New Hampshire
Healthcare quality and safety commission
and I was also part of uh work group
with Senator Sherman and Senator gray
when we were working on the workplace
violence
legislation so to lizette's point when
you ask Senator Rosenwald why was there
only one event here it this was a
serious reportable event and that it
Rose to the definition of death or
Serious injury there are many more
events outside of that definition that
occur in our organizations
and that's why there's only one
mentioned in this report and it's
because of the specificity of the
definition
if we keep that definition as one line
and then we have a much broader
definition as a second line
because I want to know that I want to
know about assaults whether the person
assaulted loses work or life it's still
to my mind a reportable thing
thank you and I know in the workplace
violence commission legislation that
there is a definition of workplace
violence and of injury so that is going
to be clearly defined so that we will be
able to report out and part of that
commission will be collecting statistics
from each of our hospitals that are
aligned with that definition so we will
be able to give you that information has
that bill been signed into law or is it
on the way correct which it's been
signed into it's been signed into law so
it's in the process of being implemented
correct so we're going to be beginning
the rulemaking process at
thank you sir representative Edwards you
have a business card so I can get you
into the minutes properly and and then
do you do you I don't I touched that
bill on the workplace violence and I
don't recall if the statistics end up in
your report or if they should they do
not and I appreciate the um
follow-through on that because I wanted
to mention that because of this
definition is what is required federally
to create this report which is partly
why the the new bill was signed into law
was to capture the population of
individuals that don't fall into this
very specific definition and that would
be a different committee or a different
group that would be reporting those
numbers so we will not see those other
numbers in your report next year correct
unless you footnoted something from
another group
so we have it in one place okay we can
do that appreciate that
um Mr chair yes sir uh we did receive
another report over the last year that
did talk about workplace violence
injuries
um or at least occurrences I should say
so we may want Health and Human Services
to look at how they're reporting so that
we can make a decision you know if we
need to or they need to uh to
consolidate them in one place and not
have them in two three places so and I
can speak to that Senator gray I know
the New Hampshire Hospital Association
has been asking hospitals to voluntarily
report for some years and I believe
that's that is what you're referencing
once we have the commission and the
mandatory reporting delineated and that
requirement in place will no longer have
the nhha requirement
thank you
thank you everyone
status update on Emma skeg Health
contract to provide Primary Care Health
Facilities and Mental Health Services in
school-based settings and parental
consent I'm waiting for the movie on
this it's a catchy title good morning
good morning chair good morning
committee yes this is a quick update for
you on the mscape school health program
the to cut to the chase the ball has
started rolling and they have met with
the Manchester School Board in
particular
it's important to reiterate that
families opt into the service I just
want to say that early on at this
question we have often gotten from this
committee and others families opt in but
amaskag has spent this fall since the
time they have received the contract
from dphs working with the Manchester
school board and the school board has
approved parental permission slips
they've approved the process flow of how
information moves from their school
nurse to the medical providers at msgate
Health they have approved the
communication plans between the school
and the families and mscape health we
have approved we dphs have approved
these plans but also also have been very
impressed by the way in which amoske has
worked directly with the school board
and the school itself we feel like
that's where the decision making really
should be the community that is
operating this needed to be comfortable
with the process and so they have
indicated they are so so far amaskag to
date has hired a physician for the
school-based health services and are
still looking to hire a medical
assistance assistant if you know anyone
please let me know the physician will
speak
all right uh The Physician will be
seeing students from the beach and
Gossler schools and will be starting in
early November so we haven't yet started
doing Hands-On clinical care we have
spent these past two months getting all
the paperwork in process making sure
that we have school board approval of
everything and that everything is
completely transparent they have hired a
behavioral health counselor to provide
Behavioral Health Services
um At McDonough Elementary they are
working to hire additional Behavioral
Health Counselors for Weston Elementary
and Northwest Elementary Schools as
proposed again an opt-in process no
parent or child will receive Services
until a parent opts in completes the
appropriate consent forms they are also
looking to hire additional community
health workers for all of the schools
that they're working to expand
Behavioral Health Services for to really
assist with referrals to services and
referrals to other
non-clinical services in the community
so that's where we are the paperwork has
been approved at the school board level
we're starting the communications with
families The Physician will be able to
start in November the Behavioral Health
Services are getting up and running as
well so I will stop there because I know
we have some interesting stuff after me
on the agenda I'm happy to answer any
questions
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair and Miss Tilly I I appreciate that
you've been so transparent on this to
include you and me talking about this in
your office like four months ago or
whenever so it's it's great seeing the
progress that's being made and what um
my hang up is still and it sounds to me
like you've addressed it or it's been
addressed uh is the the parental consent
issue you know I'm I'm I'm I want to
know more about that for example uh if
uh the the family wants to opt in for
say
some physical medical intervention
should there be trauma or something on
site you know I I could see filling out
a blanket form for that at the beginning
of a school year but then
something
such as a behavioral health counseling
I'm curious if that gets covered under
that opt-in and I'm curious if the
opt-in is per incident or or per school
year or per lifetime career the student
has with that school so there's still
details that you may not have with you
today yeah yeah after a couple of those
so I'm looking right now at an
authorization for designation of
parental consent that's one of the forms
that they have there and they have check
boxes so physical examinations female
examinations immunizations sick Care
Counseling Services health education so
the parent can check off what it is that
they are opting into
and and there's a blanket for the school
year or is it a per incident I can um
without me just scanning these papers
right now I can get back to you on that
thank you I would appreciate it if you
could uh get to the committee uh all the
forms that the parents would see I'd
like to see them too okay great we will
send that to the committee thank you
we'll send it to the chair and it'll be
thank you I do have a question that's a
tad off topic to Hampshire College
people vote for Williams or Amherst
Hampshire college is not necessarily
known for their involvement in athletics
unless it is frisbee golf
well done
thank you sir
I wrote for Williams
great
maternal mortality reports
Rhonda Siegel
Carol and naiam Segi and Daisy Goodman
and we have a third place our engineer
discovered that you could actually sit
up here
and access the microphones we have all
these microphones just waiting for
people
and Carolyn
I spent a wonderful month in Nairobi
about 15 years ago your Kenyan yes
now the first test
for people sitting at the table is what
turn on the microphone and bring it
uh good almost afternoon I am Rhonda
Siegel I am the section chief for uh the
maternal and child health uh section uh
that reports to uh director Tilly there
are many programs underneath me
including the one director Tilly just
described but um I'm here to talk about
um the maternal mortality Review
Committee this is our annual report
um I about a decade ago a little over a
decade ago
legislation was approved that enabled
DHHS specifically uh Public Health uh to
begin a maternal mortality Review
Committee in conjunction with our
partners the Northern New England
perinatal quality improvement Network
um and so that uh was really got going
in 2012 and in 2019
New Hampshire DHHS received a grant uh
from the Centers for Disease Control uh
which the purpose of the grant is to
help support state maternal mortality
review committees so it was competitive
we applied we got it this enabled us to
um contractually uh or to contract with
the Northern New England perinatal
quality improvement Network
um so I brought three of my colleagues
here
um I am a member of the mmrc
um I'm going to introduce my colleague
Victoria Flanagan who is uh an
obstructural nurse and the perinatal
Outreach educator for the Northern New
England perinatal quality improvement
Network she is also the abstractor as
noted in the report so we have two
abstractors one is my perinatal
coordinator at the Maternal Child Health
within HHS and the other is our
colleague at Napkin
Vicky okay thank you so much for
allowing me to participate in this
review I was involved in this work ever
since the Inception of it so Trish Tilly
and I have been working on this for a
long time
um what I'd like to share with you is
really the process that we go through it
which begins as a description on page
six and seven so
um what happens is that there are
several ways that patients that women
are identified who had died either
during pregnancy or within a year so
they could have been pregnant and died
prior to you know the beginning of a
year or all the way through postpartum a
year after her actually delivering her
baby our first case that we received
actually was identified through a family
member who called Maternal Child Health
looking for help because her daughter
had died and they had a four week old
baby and she was looking for help so
that case really opened our eyes to what
was happening with women of childbearing
age within that one year period and she
had died in an emergency room in a small
rural hospital and the her symptoms were
the worst headache of my life so as we
began the process of really trying to
understand as you're hearing from I
think the other people who presented to
you today you know what could have
happened and could this death a real
purpose in this is could this death have
been prevented so as we investigated
that gay a case from a small rural
community you know in Northern New
Hampshire that team much like the others
that have been described really wanted
to understand was there something they
could have done differently to have
cared for this woman before they walked
into the the room where she had been in
the emergency room and she had passed
away
our committee as you'll see on page 11
is comprised of about 28 to 29 people
which is about 50 percent event clinical
people to help us uncover some of the
the challenges of these cases before us
but also 50 from both um our public
sector you know women who are a child
bearing age but also all of our other
support services that really comprise
the care that a woman gets in our
community so I'm happy to describe more
information but it's such a robust
effort to really to really mostly
identify was it preventable and what
kinds of things both from an inpatient
setting but also from the community
services could have been more robust
that might have prevented this situation
and now introduce two of my colleagues
first the maternal and child health
epidemiologist Dr Caroline I am a Segi
and Dr Daisy Goodman uh from also from
that Quinn Daisy is the also the
director of
integrated Women's Health Services at
Dartmouth health
so thank you and we'll be back up for
questions
okay thank you all for giving us this
opportunity to share the maternal
mortality data so I love us to
um bring you all to attention of page
seven seven and eight where we have
reported the data that
um
data for 2020 and 2021
so there were five pregnant Associated
deaths in 2020 and 6 in 2021
two of those deaths occurred during
pregnancy and nine occurred postpartum
so as you can see most of the deaths are
occurring after they uh mother gives
birth
and on page eight we we have shown that
over those deaths were full cardiac were
so we also used New Hampshire aggregated
data from maternal mortality review
application that is the marine
application which we use for data
abstraction to report other
characteristics associated with deaths
which occurred in New Hampshire from
2017 to 2021 so that's
um shown on page 28 to 23 uh 28 page 30
but I love to just highlight uh page 28
so I wish to bring to your attention
that more than half of all the
pregnancies Associated deaths which
occurred in New Hampshire between 2017
to 2021 were caused by overdose and mmrc
determined that substance use disorder
and mental health were the main
contributing factors so this has been
the story over and over we are seeing
more over those deaths among the
pregnant Associated deaths and as my
colleague
Daisy will be giving you some of the
recommendations which the mmrc comes up
with so that we can prevent these uh
deaths thank you all
thank you for the opportunity to discuss
our maternal mortality committee
recommendations as are outlined in this
report Pages 8 through 10 and to give
you an update on our progress in
implementing some of those
recommendations
that implementation is done as a
collaboration between DHHS and napkin
so as mentioned before the purpose of
maternal mortality review is really to
identify the causes and factors that
contribute to maternal deaths and then
to identify whether and how they could
have been prevented and then
subsequently because we're not in this
just to report we're all also in this to
do something about it the committee
makes recommendations about areas where
Improvement could have happened that
could have been potentially preventative
um so
um in this report uh the mmrc
recommendations are described and I'll
give you just a sample of those and the
implementation of them by the New
Hampshire DHHS and napkin
um so for first the mmrc has recommended
that New Hampshire participate in the
National Alliance for Innovation on
maternal Health which is a national
program of the American College of
Obstetricians and gynecologists which
aims to reduce maternal mortality this
is implemented state by state and I
think 49 out of 50 states or maybe by
now it's 50 states our members and we're
excited that in 2020 New Hampshire was
approved for participation in this
Alliance
um secondly
um the mmrc recommended on that napkin
develop and Implement a harm reduction
education program for all birthing
facilities which will educate both
providers and families about the risk
for postpartum relapse and the potential
for overdose based on our New Hampshire
data which shows that overdose is indeed
the leading cause of loss of life for
this group of mothers
so napkin provided information on how to
obtain naloxone which is a life-saving
medication which can be administered by
a family member or member of the general
public to reverse an open overdose and
save a life this is uh free through the
New Hampshire doorway program so we were
able to collaborate with that program to
ensure that all of our hospitals knew
that this was accessible to families and
some of the hospitals I've been able to
actually get a supply of naloxone and
dispense it to the families of patients
who have substance use conditions to
make sure that they have the ability to
reverse and overdose at home
um and also to develop a naloxone
education program for nursing staff
nepen also holds monthly webinars to
support New Hampshire birth providers as
was also recommended by the committee
and finally on New Hampshire
mmrc recommended that nepkin work with
DHHS to make sure there was a training
for hospitals to implement a national
peace and discharge education program on
post-birth warning signs one of which is
the worst ever headache that my
colleague Vicki referred to so that all
New Hampshire hospitals are now
providing patient education about those
signs and symptoms to watch Opera and
how to get immediate help to patients at
um
I think that I made stuff there although
there are some recommendations that are
ongoing and will take longer to
implement I'll just mention a few of
those
um mmrc also recommends that New
Hampshire DHHS and napkin continue to
develop and deliver public education on
the importance of prenatal care
especially for people with substance use
disorders and the importance of getting
Medical Care during the postpartum year
and also to partner with our New
Hampshire colleagues who are working on
community suicide prevention training as
we do know that other mental health
conditions and lack of mental health
services are a significant contributor
to the deaths that we see so this has
been a big collaborative effort and if
you look at the end of the
um the report there in the appendices
there are some of the public education
materials which have been developed
there
um and finally mmrc also recommended
that the legislature consider some
increasing funding for direct services
including improving access to Mental
Health Services and maternal Health
Services generally for the full first
postpartum year and I know that members
of this committee have been strongly in
support of the expansion of postpartum
Medicaid and we do very much appreciate
that it's very much in aligned with the
findings of the committee
oh thank you
representative Nelson
thank you very much for taking my
question
if a woman is pregnant carrying the baby
uh say I don't know six months
if they were given the the mother the
the drug now the accident if they were
given that during the pregnancy does it
affect the baby at all uh yes great
question and the American College of
Obstetricians and gynecologist has
directly addressed that because of
course it's a concern about any
medication that we give to a pregnant
person is it going to cause any any harm
the answer is that this actually would
save both the mother and the baby
because very unfortunately if the mother
dies the mother is the baby's life
support system Right In Utero and if the
mother is not breathing and can't
provide oxygen then both are lost so
um ACOG strongly recommends
administering naloxone in the case of an
overdose in a pregnant person
anyone else representative soloway
thank you Mr chairman team thank you uh
I I want to tread lightly into uh Dr Nay
masagi's area uh one of the problems in
epidemiology is the problem of the
missing data
and I think that you've done a wonderful
job here reporting on deaths identifying
which of those were preventable
what doesn't get and I must say that
your team which is clearly a very
effective team
um is an expensive team
and one might look at this report and
look at your team and say well 18 deaths
that's a very expensive effort and it's
dealing with 18 deaths but what doesn't
show up here is the number of deaths
that were prevented that's the missing
data
and I think that this oversight
committee and the state needs to
understand
that in public and Community Health
generally in epidemiology
the ghost is the missing data and you
can't produce that data it doesn't exist
you can't collect it but you need to
advertise you need to publicize that you
have saved many many many more lives
then you lost and that's worth the cost
thank you Mr chairman
I'm trying to think of the last time I
witnessed a conversation between two
epidemiologists
if you'll permit me Mr chairman it is
known in the field that if you laid all
the epidemiologists in the world end to
end you still couldn't reach a
conclusion
because of insufficient data
thank you so much that's uh one of I we
never thought about it that way like we
need to observe and ask hospitals out
there like
um pregnant women who come in and
they're administered the naloxone so
that way we start collecting the numbers
of uh the cases that we are prevented
because of this um health education that
we are giving because of the naloxone
that we are providing for free so that's
a wonderful and uh wonderful uh point
and I'll love to take it back to our
community so that we can work with
hospitals in trying to monitor these
prevent prevented uh cases thank you
yeah we are tracking at least the number
uh the amount of naloxone that is being
distributed and we've just um so we will
be able to report that next year
foreign
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair I I think I have about four or
five questions that are would contribute
to our understanding of this report
um uh the first point I want to jump on
is a representative saloways uh in terms
of it's very hard to measure the those
that you've prevented but I'm wondering
if if a more generic benchmarking could
take place to where we just uh take
these as a percentage of total live
births and then we Benchmark that
percentage nationally so we at least
have some gross indicator of whether or
not we're in line or out of line or head
of line or you know I I think so I'm not
an epidemiologist for the record but I'm
just curious if that kind of a benchmark
would provide useful insight
yeah okay
um so I I just want to um interject uh
we um New Hampshire participate in
monthly actually more than one uh call
with our national colleagues and we're
very much representative of other states
both in terms of our deaths and and what
causes the deaths so
so I don't I have no judgment on how New
Hampshire is doing relative I'm just
trying to address the question of how
what kind of a metric might be useful in
a report like this in the future that's
that was my only point there
um and then I I guess I'm obligated to
jump to the part of the recommendation
dealing with budgets
I'm looking I had it for a moment uh
page nine
under ongoing recommendations there's a
paragraph two that talks about increased
funding for Direct services and so first
I want to ask about dedicated funds and
then I want to ask about the governor
Governor's budget process so on on the
dedicated funds is there now a dedicated
fund that would support your program
efforts
do you know if there's a dedicated fund
Federal funding we just had a federal
site visit yesterday it also receives
General funding part of which goes into
looking at maternal health care when you
say General you mean State funding yes
I'm sorry no that's all right because
we're going to struggle with definitions
a little bit what I'm what I'm asking
about is a dedicated fund a a special
fund that's been set up strictly for
maternal mortality right uh no there is
a again there are dedicated funds for
Maternal Child and but that goes through
the governor's budget you get that goes
the governor through our budget so we
put together a budget director Tilly
looked at it our fiscal people looked at
it and went up to the commissioner
yes but there is dedicated funding
towards Caroline the more dedicated his
uh synonym it's used in multiple ways
and so you're using it differently than
what I'm using yeah okay
um so so so that's fine because what I'm
hearing is that you probably don't have
a dedicated Fund in the sense that I'm
using the term I think so okay there's
there's actually a committee that uh of
the house that looks at dedicated funds
used throughout the executive branch and
so I'm assuming that you don't have a
line item in that dedicated funds book
and I'm just thinking about creating one
for you and and how we would Source it
um so then on the governor's budget I
assume that in the governor's budget
process you all provide a recommendation
to the governor the governor reviews it
the that Governor's budget comes to the
house we look at it that includes
Federal money that's been earmarked or
targeted I'm going to avoid dedicated
to to this purpose and then we augment
it with State funds that's correct okay
in the previous
in the previous budget
how did your budget request to the
governor compare with the final budget
that you received
you know
it's either you know the governor's
budget included your amount of the
microphone yeah yeah we still have we
haven't run out of microphones yet Ms
Tilly
thank you that's a great question so um
for maternal and child health we
received what we asked for
um and again Maternal Child Health is
very broad one of the things that I also
want to note and I appreciate this line
of questioning
um as Rhonda described as Mr Siegel
described we have some federal funds
that help with the review process that's
just to help us get the data right and
help support our epidemiologists in the
report itself there's a recommendation
for additional funds for some of the
Direct Services that is often outside
the scope of Public Health and certainly
outside the scope sometimes of maternal
and child health as well so to your
point this is very complicated
okay so because I'm a simple guy what
I'm hoping is that during the governor's
budget process somewhere the money that
you're asking for in paragraph two is
requested somewhere in the governor's
budget so that the process can consider
this request as a normal line of
business and not as something
exceptional to how we ordinarily put
money out there yeah and again thank you
for that question so I think it is some
of the things that are requested or
recommended within this report are
specifically around Direct Services may
show up in the substance use the
substance misuse budget in the
behavioral health budget in the
governor's commission budget as well so
that is where we would often find those
lines
um you know there are other pieces like
prenatal care that might be found within
public health so again it's there's lots
of different places it could show up in
the budgeting process to your point
so thank you for the follow-up
all right so
I am trying to help you I'm helping you
help me help you which is on this
paragraph two of the recommendations
I I could use something supplemental
that would provide more clarity about
how much more money you want and what
specific budget line items because I I
don't have the ability or the staff to
go through the governor's entire Health
Care budget and figure out what your
what you want so so if you can I Mr
Williams maybe you can help communicate
this or Miss Tilly you know the idea of
if you if you if you supplement this
with a supplemental budget by line item
where you want State money or some other
money I I would have be happy if I'm
still around in division three to
consider that that proposal thank you
thank you all right
he chairs division three of Finance
or the Scrooge depending on what happens
you're not the Scrooge anybody else any
any any any
going several times gone thank you all
for coming up here thank you thank you
we have one item uh a request that was
made by representative Nelson he would
like to give an update to something he
had said in September and I think this
would be quite helpful and it'll also be
very brave so representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to read
the first part quickly so that can
eventually get put in the minutes
several minutes ago someone expressed
concern that fewer and fewer of the
elderly are seeking Medical Care in my
area of Southern Carroll County we had
highs we have a high elderly population
many have been using the Frisbee walk-in
services or clinic in Wakefield we re in
the recent month or so almost all the
services provided at this Clinic have
ceased this has resulted in many of
those using the clinic to just stop
seeing a doctor and taking advantage of
the services that have been provided the
walk-in clinic doctor Services Testing
Lab Etc recently The Fosters paper ran
an article about the sudden loss of 16
plus doctors at frisbee This concerns me
both as a resident of the four towns
that I represent but also those residing
in Rochester and surrounding areas I
recognize there is a shortage of doctors
and nurses technicians Etc but the
sudden departure is my concern concern
something has to be looked at I have
done some additional research I ask
anyone receiving services or connected
with Frisbee for their thoughts while
many will not talk I sense there is a
great concern over what is happening
employees are frustrated in medical
related folks are upset occasionally I
run into a New Hampshire doctor in the
area of the state and they say they hear
there it is a mess I find it interesting
that many of the doctors nurses Etc that
are no longer with frisbee show up at
Wentworth system they certainly did not
just move out of the area I have stopped
at frisbee several stopped in a frisbee
several times times to speak with the
administrator and left my card this is
where it gets new we have finally we
were finally able to meet in person this
past week Mr Jones a frisbee
administrator indicated that he has been
at the job for just one year he
mentioned the fiscal problems inherited
when HCA took over frisbee he mentioned
this critical shortage of doctors and
nurses technicians Etc he indicated they
are trying to recruit these folks he
never responded to the sudden as to why
the sudden departure of the doctors we
ended the meeting and we had a very nice
meeting that's it
it's it in the minutes
clerk request uh representative Nelson
it it seems to me that what you just
said is is really close to this document
you provided earlier if if it if I'm
right would you would you mind tweaking
this and and sending a fresh copy I'd be
happy to include it verbatim in the
minutes I plan to send that to you this
afternoon thank you sir the difference
is not his his update is not in there so
I I know so that's what he's going to do
when you know that yeah that's good we
both agree yeah thank you great minds
indeed we do all right the next meeting
is November 18th the third Friday and
it's at one o'clock and probably here